alo nấu cho bạn ạ
anh alo alo
À hôm nay Như tiêu đề các bạn thấy thì
hôm nay sẽ là cậu buổi vượt qua
cốt cũng như là tài liệu các bạn hiểu
nhóm nào muốn đăng ký bảo vệ
các nhóm đều muốn bảo vệ rồi làm đồ án
xong khỏi làm vui không ạ thì các nhòm
có thể nhắn bình luận để mà để mình
trượt qua tài liệu nó cả vượt qua
hôm nay có thể để mô thì bảo vệ thử luôn
cũng được đấy
vượt qua tính năng có thừa thứ II
Ờ thì đầu tiên thì à mình có tâm sự một
chút là
anh ngủ không biết Thứ ba là buổi khóa
này thì chứ ai nói cả nhưng mà tự mình
cảm thấy đó là nhiều lúc mình dậy mấy
cái nó hơi bị chưa sâu một tí kiểu dạng
là nó sẽ hơi khó với kiểu phải dùng tới
khóc đúng với những bạn mới vì bây giờ
các bạn mới học ruhr tầm Chỉ 3 tháng ở
căng đấy Đúng nho mình đã dạy các bạn về
những kiến thức có thể nâng cao thật Chứ
ở người chuyên nourish còn chờ có thể
chưa biết em mình khẳng định có thật bởi
vì a nhiều khá mình dạy không có nằm ở
trên tài liệu của Vario các bạn tìm
Không có đâu Mình phải mua khóa học hoặc
là mình phải tự ngọt thêm có cái còn
không đề cập tới trong khóa học nào cả
mình vẫn người tự màu để chở như thế thì
về giá sản là các bạn sẽ bị quá tải
đề thi thực tế thực tế ở đây nó vừa là
nó hơi bị nhược điểm một tí đó là việc
và khi mà các bạn xem livestream như này
Đấy do mà mình livestream mình cố
livestream chỉ chỉ dạy một buổi nó kiến
thức nó chỉ tầm một tí tí thôi Thế trái
việc quá Tại kết hợp với việc là kiến
thức lấy như mình Hưởng ơi nó nó trẻ
mang tính chất tham khảo các bạn gỗ ốp
và cho cái
đồ ăn các bạn một kì à các bạn chưa đủ
kiến thức để mà ngồi làm chi tiết và cẩn
thận được như thế cũng như à Có rất
nhiều hàm các bạn còn chưa Rồi biết các
bạn dùng nhiều bạn sẽ khó hiểu cái kiểu
như thế thực tế thực tế nếu mà các bạn
để ý thì toàn bộ những cái kiến thức gọi
là gọi là một cách tương đối CRD xem
thêm sửa xóa mình đã dậy xong ở trong từ
lâu rồi mà các bạn chỉ cần có đủ mình
đấy kiến thức cũng có thể làm được đoán
22 khi con còn những cái sau mình dậy
thì là thường là nó liên quan bài toán
nghiệp vụ và đương nhiên sẽ còn những
cái hàm và những cách mình mình cần tối
ưu cốt hay là mình đều dạng là Viết cốt
sao cho nó dễ nhìn và Tùng minh hơn thì
cái đấy là cái để mà các bạn về cho tham
khảo và chứ không phải là các bạn áp I
Nguyên Toàn bộ những cái mình thường hay
dậy để các bạn vào đồ ăn các bạn thì bản
thân các bạn vừa khó hiểu bởi vì nó mới
cái việc là nó kiểu dạng là
chỗ khác nhưng Giả sử khi một mình chơi
để mô cái phần mà bạn làm thì bạn sẽ
không hiểu gì cả nghe nói trong à Cái
này nó là hơi bị nhược điểm một tí khi
mà dậy Khi mà dạy Online kiểu ngày thì
thứ nhất là mình không phải ngày nào
mình dậy lại đúng cái crdc Jose ngày nào
dạy thế à
dậy CD để các bạn phải tránh được đúng
không ạ chắc chắn mình cũng sẽ phải dậy
game mới mà dậy thì mới thì thực ra là
nó sẽ bị đến với ngõ là các bạn sẽ quá
tải vì các bạn còn chưa thẩm thấu hết
rồi cái cũ cái cũ Các bạn chơi thẩm thấu
hết Đấy đấy là nhược điểm của việc học
online và trực tiếp như thế này nó Các
bạn xem có thể có thể xem một cách tham
khảo thôi chứ không không thể ốp hoàn
toàn vào được thế việc là có nhiều bạn
mình biết là
các bạn lấy học một cách chọn lọc hơn
một tí đó là các bạn để dừng lại ở video
tự tận video buổi thứ mười mấy rồi Bạn
ấy không xem livestream trực tiếp nữa mà
vì a bạn ấy không thể không thể theo kịp
được là bạn ấy kiểu
Anh biết rằng mà học đến đấy là đã đủ
kiến thức để làm được đón hay rồi Cái
đấy cũng là một cái hay đấy Bạn ấy không
nói mà bạn ấy thỉnh thoảng vào xem những
cái buổi chữa của mình thôi chứ không
xem những cái buổi cầu rằng dạng nâng
cao hơn gì cả thấy con cái việc là tôi
dậy nâng cao thì một cái rồi chia sẻ
thêm tôi không thể chính tôi cũng sẽ
chán game ngày nào tụi nó đi anh lại cảm
ơn các bạn đã biết rồi Đúng giấc và các
bạn sẽ chán khi vào xem Toàn những cái
mà mình đã biết rồi chắc chắn tôi phải
dậy nên mới đúng ạ Nhưng mà quan trọng
là khi dậy nên mới nhiều thì các bạn sẽ
bị quá tải kiến thức
I so với cái đón hay thực sự các bạn cần
cái lượng kiến thức các bạn chỉ cần một
cách tương đối thôi cho đón hạn đã làm
được đón hay rồi đấy Nói chung là cái
này là liên quan bài toán việc là các
bạn sẽ hệ sẽ phải tự sàng lọc kiến thức
để các bạn học
Ừ đúng ạ
Ừ nhưng mà tôi vẫn cảm thấy vẫn còn phần
lỗi gì đó Khi mà nhưng mà tôi
Cô dạy có nhiều bệnh nhân cao quá sẽ các
bạn không theo được ví dụ ngay bây giờ
các bạn thấy là lượng người xem nó sẽ bị
giảm hơn so với hồi trước của vì không
phải ai theo được đến đến đến giây phút
này có người có thể che mái dự thì chỉ
nghe cho biết chứ không thể áp dụng được
nhưng mình sẽ không phải những video đi
bởi vì mình biết có gì về sau các bạn
nếu muốn tìm tài liệu muốn nói à tham
khảo lại thì có nơi để mà xem nhưng mà
nó đúng là nó không có đánh thấy mục lục
nó không có kiểu chi tiết để các bạn vì
sao biết được các bạn sẽ phải ngồi mò
lại hơn mất công bản thân đưa các bạn
hỏi lại tôi những cái mà tôi từng dậy
rồi tôi tôi chỉ nhớ tôi dậy rồi không
nhớ được cụ thể tại video nào luôn chứ
đừng nói là dây thử bao nhiêu đúng bạn
thì đấy do mà thêm một cái lợi nữa mà
khi mà mình về bên Spiderman thì mình sẽ
lên khung chương trình lại một cách cẩn
thận cũng như là mục lục các thử thử em
từng buổi từng buổi từng cái giáo án nó
rất là kiểu chi tiết cố chi tiết hết sức
có thể để mà
có gì mà kiểu khi mà dạy
các bạn chính các bạn về sau các bạn
muốn xem lại thì có thể xem trên nền
tảng đấy cũng được hoặc áo tôi sẽ lấy
video đấy Đang lại lên đây nhưng mà sẽ
lấy mục lục hay gì đó nữa Đi kèm để các
bạn cậu biết được là Ừ mình muốn xem lại
về đây là quần lại mua đồ hướng mình xem
lại ở video nào những video nào
đi mua đồ cơ bản thì được ở trên tài
liệu có rồi Bây giờ anh ấy dạy thêm
những cái hàm mà chưa tài liệu không có
thì nọ thì thì xem ở video nào rồi thì
bao nhiêu đúng không ạ Đấy chẳng hạn thế
mấy ông hình dung ông ạ chảy tiếp theo
là
a tiếp theo là mình sẽ cắt một vài cái
video cũ như mình đã từng nói là về sau
mình sẽ đôi khi mình sẽ chia sẻ vài cái
mẹo cốt những cái video những cái cách
tối ưu Vân thì sẽ cắt lại và mình sẽ
đăng lên trang lại lên kênh này của mình
sau này không phải thử không phải kênh
này tôi về sau sẽ không dạy học nữa mà
sẽ không hẳn thuê hướng dạy học hoàn
toàn thôi nhưng mà nó vẫn sẽ có đấy thì
tôi sẽ cắt lên và tôi sẽ đưa lên một vì
có tôi thấy à Hồi trước chính tôi là
người họ claire tôi cũng rất muốn là cậu
học hỏi tôi muốn nữa à Lên YouTube theo
dõi một loa thôi gọi là Real sân Altis
Adele van nâng cao để mà cầu vượt theo
dõi tất cả các mặt kênh đấy thi ở những
cây định kênh đấy dạy vẫn còn giáo dục
cơ bản có rất nhiều cái nằm trên tài
liệu rồi nó giống kiểu dậy sau người mà
không nơi để đọc tài liệu Hình như thế
nó không có hẳn cái gì đó hay hay ho lắm
con những cái mà hay ho thật thì họ lại
bán sự khóa học mất rồi đấy Thế là để và
tôi đã mua bị khóa học với cậu sen vài
cái có phải cái được à
em gà tôi sẽ có thể chia sẻ lại được thì
tôi sẽ chia sẻ lại nhớ đến Hưng Yên là
theo phong cách của mình có một sự thật
ở đó là khi mình xem thế mà mình ôm y
nguyên đem về thì nó là ông Minh Nguyên
đăng lên đấy đôi khi nó vi phạm bản
quyền Đôi khi mình mình xem nó vẫn là
kiến thức đúng ạ nhưng vẫn học cái nước
đấy Đang lại thêm một phong cách khác
một tí đấy Ở một sự học hỏi một sự cải
tiến cái gì đó Đang lên lại không bị vi
phạm bản quyền nên là cái khái niệm bản
quyền tôi thấy nó hơi bị mong manh nhưng
mà nhưng mà với tôi con đỉa
đó là kiến thức thì nên miễn phí và nên
chia sẻ cậu lặng là ai cũng có thể tiếp
cận được hơn là kiểu dạng là là cẩu
Ê hồi trước tôi nhớ Tôi từng xanh bạn và
tôi chia sẻ Cái vụ mà tôi thường xuyên
lại với bạn thôi rồi nó kiểu thôi không
thể chia sẻ tài liệu cho tôi không được
của vì nó liên quan đến vi phạm việc đi
nhưng mà Nếu giả sử tôi xem những cái
video lấy rồi tôi hiểu làm lại không hẳn
là đạo nhái 100 như nó cho kiểu gần như
cũng nói lại kiến thức của trong video
đấy thì lại đây chứ nhận lại không Tí vi
phạm việc cái hơi buồn cười nhưng nó lại
sự thật là như thế
kênh của mình hiện tại và sau này thì
chắc là sẽ tưởng là thế đâu nhà như mình
nói là sẽ cái kênh này thật tên là Villa
blog rồi có lý do cả vì về sau mình sẽ
cậu dạng là làm vi Locker Block cái thứ
thứ
a blogger
lấy từ bên trên Facebook chưa đạt xanh
thôi nghĩa là Vlog thì nó sẽ cũng được
số vietlott là tôi nhớ là tại sao ai như
tôi nhớ Tại sao là tên là Vlog rồi flop
Nếu mà tôi tra thì nó sẽ là hiểu rồi
ừ ừ
ngoài đời tôi mang tên ở trên Facebook
và blog bởi vì nó tôi đăng bài đôi khi
không có video ừ thế này là tôi muốn mọi
nền tảng tôi sẽ tên là blog anh theo
kiểu là bởi vì tôi đang đôi khi không
phải video cho đăng hình ảnh Tôi đang
bài viết kiểu kể cả trên Facebook trên
insta hoặc ở trên top và các thứ tư Tik
Tok thì phải video rồi luôn đại khá như
thế Ở hướng theo Cấm là vì là kiểu dạng
là bị Locker tức là người thỉnh thoảng
chia sẻ quan điểm của mình để tiếp theo
mình mình cho tâm sự nhanh lại lúc thế
này
Đang nghe cái gì
ê sai là cái gì còn chỉ rõ không giàu
lên được đó chính là khái niệm bình yên
tĩnh mình
Ăn tối tại cho mọi người nghe nhé có bị
to quá
khi tôi cảm thấy cũng to rất minh đúng
không
cho mọi người xem lại nhé ừ ừ
là Khái niệm và thời gian mình nhớ hồi
lúc còn học đại học quá trình kinh doanh
rất là nhiều thứ bằng kinh doanh quần áo
thanh niên vé máy bay và trái mình làm
chắc được 3 4 tháng không thấy nhiều kết
quả thành chịu cái khác do tim anh nhìn
lại thì gắp ra là tất cả nó là cái gì
thì nếu mà mình kiên nhẫn theo đuổi nó
mình giặt theo thời gian đó mà tìm hiểu
về nó thì chắc chắn là sẽ thấy kết quả
như bạn hãy Nguyên lúc đó mà không kiên
nhẫn cho nên là mình tốn thời gian nghỉ
qua Nghĩa là nghĩa quan Giữ lại lắp cái
mà nhiều bạn sẽ mắc phải đó là bạn không
có kiên nhẫn hết chả là bạn đi học Bạn
tìm việc phải làm kinh doanh chọn một
cái và kiên trì nó có thời gian đầu có
khả năng cao là các bạn sẽ không thấy
kết quả và các bạn đến dự đoán trước là
nó sẽ không có kết quả nhiều để cho cái
giọng của bạn không có cao để mà nở nãy
rồi sau đó kiên trì thực hiện Tân bước
từng bước trong các bạn chọn chắc chắn
và thời gian nó sẽ trả và kết quả vậy
hoài năm bạn nghe thấy có phải lâu nhưng
mà buồn một cái là thời gian nó bay hết
lên kiên trì với các bạn chọn thì gọi
Năm sau phải sẽ kết quả còn không thì
sao ngoài năm bạn sẽ nhìn qua nhìn lại
rồi lại tự hỏi là của xong không có được
cái gì hết nè sang làm gì rồi chỉ nhỏ
không rõ à à
mình có tuyển người cho nên mình có câu
Qua siêu vi của một số bạn và sau đây là
những cái lỗi mà rất nhiều bạn mắc phải
chứng như bạn nói quá nhiều mà mong muốn
của bạn yêu bạn dành nguyên cái phần đầu
của còn quan trọng nhất của branson mấy
nói về à trong 2 năm bạn muốn gì trong 5
năm bạn muốn gì của con mình là nhà
Tuyển dụng thì sao mình nó có quan tâm
tới bạn muốn gì như quan tâm tên bạn có
thể mang lại giá trị gì cho mình cho nên
là các bạn phải đổi lại khi bạn phải nói
về những cái giá trị mà bạn có thể đem
lại cho công ty thứ hai là nhiều bạn đặt
sai đối tượng con miền Bạn phải đặt cái
công việc mới nhất cái công việc mà bạn
đang làm Hiện tại trên cùng rồi sau đó
theo thứ tự thời gian cũ dần ta đi công
việc hiện tại của bạn đó là các công
việc liên quan nhất sẽ nhất quan trọng
nhất là phải đã nói lên dùm cục cái thứ
ba là nhiều bạn không có tự tin bình
tĩnh tòi những phim mà bạn tự chắc có
khả năng dùng phim của bạn là 700 510
bạn không thử tin nữa thì làm sao lại
chuyện cái tên đã được cho mình vô quần
nó biết là bạn không giỏi Bạn phải tự
tin lên để mơ nhiên mời nghiệm mũ cái CP
là các bạn phỏng vấn và bạn phải tự tin
trong các siêu vi đó bạn mới có cơ hội
có được điều đó 3 sai lầm của các bạn
sinh viên khi biết C chỉ có tuyển người
cho nên mình có
kéo dạng là sinh viên ở nhiều hơn gặp
như mình hiện tại thì mình thấy khá hay
nói chung là chú tục đề xuất cụ khác chả
là người người theo dõi người theo dõi
tôi kiểu cũng cũng thích chả cũng theo
dõi và Facebook Đề xuất cho tôi ờ
Ừ thì hai video lại một video các bạn
thấy nói về cái độ với nhẫn như tự mình
từng nói rồi thì nó là
Ừ thì thì chỉ nó là là kiểu dạng na ná
giống như anh ấy bảo giống như kiểu tập
chim với đôi khi kết quả ngày một ngày
hai không thấy thế Mình không để đánh
giá được mình cũng đừng nản Vội Mà mình
mình cũng được nhảy việc liên tục mình
ít nhất là mình cũng phải kiểu
Ừ mình cũng phải thẩm thấu nó một khoảng
thời gian để mà mình sau đó thì mình mới
để đưa cái đoạn là nó phù hợp hay không
Và nếu thực sự mình muốn thành công thì
sẽ khả năng mình sẽ phải tốn thời gian
rất nhiều với nó chứ không phải là kiểu
người một ngày ngày hai là thấy được kết
quả không ạ Có nhiều bạn kiểu mới học
lập trình nản ra thì bởi vì a bạn này có
quá nhiều suy nghĩ có nhiều lựa chọn và
bạn ấy mông lông nên phải ra bạn ấy cậu
ở cầu dạng là không đặt âm nó hoàn toàn
và cứ nghĩa nó có thể không phù hợp nên
chắc chắn là mình cũng phải lên à
cho nên bỏ thời gian công sức nó đến
ngưỡng ở đó nữa thì mình mới có thể bạn
nhận xét được tất cả những cái gì đấy
đúng ạ Giống như bạn các bạn
các bạn đang ngồi xem video của mình để
mình tại ra thật các bạn đã đi đến các
chặng đường này rồi sao bạn cũng cũng
biết được gần nên như thế nào rồi Trang
hợp mình không cần lời giải thích về vụ
này nhưng mà nhưng mà theo mình thì kiên
nhẫn này cái nhẫn có thể trong mỗi công
việc mà rất nhiều cái thứ khác nữa
cho ngành công nghiệp tin phải mình
nghĩa sàng lọc Cái quan trọng nhất điều
tối quan trọng nhất vẫn khỏe thông minh
mà kiên nhẫn kiên nhẫn vừa Mỹ từng nói
rồi đấy cái nhẫn khách hàng như nhận với
sếp kiên nhẫn với cốt thì mà vấn đề
rất nhiều cái gì
à à
A
em hết
à Còn cái video còn cái video nói về vi
C vi này thì thời ca Mình cũng từng nói
rồi đó là kiểu
khi mà các bạn đi phỏng vấn thì quan
trọng nhất là các bạn cái sự tự tin nó
nó Mình cũng từng nói về cái công ty
bằng cấp cũng từng khuyên mình thế rồi
nó kiểu
3 cách để các bạn lừa dối khách hàng
nhìn đầu tiên các bạn phải thuyết phục
được bản thân sản phẩm tốt đã thì cũng
giống như là kiểu bây giờ các bạn đi
phỏng vấn bằng chất là các bạn bán các
bạn a cho họ và họ phải tin được các bạn
là được việc nếu các bạn phải tự tin vào
chính mình như đi thằng đấy các bạn phải
tự tin thôi đấy nếu mà các bạn không tin
được chính mình thì thì không ai tin
được các bạn cả nên là cứ mạnh dạn thoải
mái các thứ thứ
Ừ nếu mà xử ông vẫn chưa tự tin đi thì
ông tôi nhẩm đừng của đi làm ông không
phải khi nào mà cảm thấy nó dồn mình đến
bước đường cùng mình phải đấu tranh vì
nó rất là thứ thì lúc ấy ông tự tin luôn
bất lắm và cũng sẽ thể hiện được cái
bản thân bộc lộ bản thân ra chứ đi đi
làm hay là làm mọi thứ trong sự dè các
thứ thứ ra đấy không tự nhiên có người
người này người kia nhưng mà sẽ sẵn tôi
nghĩa là gì
em thấy cái việc khi ông đi phỏng vấn gì
cái
ô tô bị tự ti các thứ thứ
vị trí khiến cho người ta không đánh giá
ông ấy chính sát đấy chứ Khi ông phải có
một cái gì sẵn rồi để mà khoe người ta
ví dụ là sửa cái đoán này là sử Em không
biết nói năng gì mấy ở đã làm nhưng
không sao cả Nhưng mà kỹ năng cốt của em
tốt bởi vì đã xem qua dự án này thấy kỹ
năng em tốt rồi còn chấp nhận còn xem
xét được không có gì để khoe thì người
ta đánh giá ông không biết qua cái gì
qua phải bên ngoài à
cả hai hiểu người đang nhìn được thẩm
thấu được bên trong Không không đúng ạ
Tôi nghĩ ý nó tự tin
và quan trọng là cái tự tin thì ông sẽ
lấy từ đâu không phải tự nhiên nó cũng
không có gì không tự tin thì thì nó say
quá rồi Đúng kiểu như đã cất thật ông
mới bỏ cả
ăn bùa và cũng phải có cái gì đó thì cái
tôi vẫn thường hay xem nó chính là sắc
anh
Sa tanh nó một cái thứ là chuyện cho
mình củng cố hơn phải cái phỏng vấn ở
cái tự tin thuyết trình các hướng rất là
hai ngày nào tôi xem sắp tay thứ
thương vụ Bạc Tỷ Cá thứ mình không có
tiền nhưng mà nó cho mình xem để mà để
mà kiểu học học hỏi biết được thêm rất
nhiều kiến thức cũng như ý tưởng luôn có
rất nhiều ý tưởng luôn đấy cũng như là
Kiều
ai biết được mà chính những người Việt
của mình đang xem giúp anh Việt nhá sang
nước ngoài thì tôi lại xe buýt không
chứng người Việt mình Họ đã nghĩ đã
những gì đang cố gắng làm những cái điều
gì rất nhiều cái to lớn và thực cũng có
rất nhiều cái rất là chém gió ông cũng
gọi là nổ Giá hay nhiều cái vấn đề gì đó
đúng không ạ thì mình cũng nhìn ở đấy
chứ nghiện đúng không ạ
a tiếp theo là mình có hai video này
nhưng mình sẽ không mở lên hai cái video
này thì mình nói qua bí cũng Hôm trước
mình nói có hơi bị Hôm trước mình bảo là
mình cũng cũng cũng có suy nghĩ việc à
Có khi là mình sẽ không làm à
a blogger được bởi vì đã có quá nhiều
người làm được lắp cơ rất nhiều Jingle
streamer rất nhiều bloggers với thử thử
sau đó khi mà hôm nay đã xem xong 2
video này
một video này video hôm trước cứ xem đi
dao này là adelin adelin
Villa H2O
ở cây cái hai cặp đôi này hay vì sao tôi
biết tuổi có anh anh con trai thì lớn
tuổi hơn mình
bạn con cái con nhỏ tuổi hơn mình nhưng
ổn
anh cũng tình cờ thôi nhưng mà họ ổn
phết thì
à à
về phía họ review về việc là đi máy bay
13 tướng đi khoang hạng thương gia Sao
Đỏ cũng của Vietnam Airline nhá sau đó
Thì hôm vừa rồi ta vừa xem của anh Vinh
xô Vinh vật vờ thì cũng đi 14 tiếng cũng
hạng thương gia để mà say thế mà
để bể mà cậu hả
ưu điểm kiểu review về Hằng Apple ra mắt
sự kiện thi Ừ hai đứa đi đây cùng cái
đoạn đầu cùng review về cái hạn thương
gia của Vietnam Airlines
đề thi giá vé núp tung kiểu xấp xỉ nhau
luôn nó kêu cũng á
chú tiểu hạn Hưng gia bán xấp xỉ nhau
nhỉ
Nhưng mà mình thấy là hai bên một bên
chê một bên sen
khen rất rất nhiều chính xác như thế thì
lúc đầu tôi xem cái video trên thôi cảm
thấy à hẳn thứ ra kia đúng là đắt tiền
tiền nào của đấy rồi cậu đúng kiểu lên
thiên đường ở trên trên lên thì đường
đúng nghĩa mà bay trên trời đây rồi các
thứ thứ còn nay anh vinh vợ anh giá thì
tôi thấy không hẳn xuống địa ngục đâu nó
hơi quá Nhưng nó khiến cho mình bị tình
mắt lên đấy nghĩa là từ ga nó không hẳn
đường lắm Chẳng qua là ờ ừ nóng mọi thứ
sang chảnh thân thứ nhưng có khi không
phù hợp với Cứ cho là không phù hợp với
người bình dân như tôi đi nhỡ đâu có
nhiều bạn thì thích kiểu đấy quen rồi
đấy nhưng mà ừ
Ừ nhưng mà nói chung thì lỡ như một bên
thì một bên anh Vinh anh Vinh thì được
Apple bao từ a đến z cũng chắc là không
được ở bên Vietnam Airlines tài trợ để
quảng cáo mình ra chỗ Cứ thoải mái mà
bình luận thôi còn là bên trên thì hình
như vẫn phải tự mua vé nhưng mà được
viện bên Việt Nam Airlines ưu ái các thứ
xong rồi còn viết thư cảm ơn nên thành
ra Kiểu cái cách họ nhận xét mọi thứ thì
nó có vẻ là nó hơi bị chiên vị dùng Chắc
thế Chắc thấy không biết được bởi vì do
đọc bình luận thì bảo dụ điển hình nhá
để nhắc đi anh Vinh keo và đồ ăn rất là
giờ được mỗi hoa quả còn bên video ở
trên thì hen hen mọi thứ đồ ăn luôn đồ
uống các thứ thử thì à
Ờ Ờ thứ 2 kiểu Ừ ở góc nhìn khác nhau
khiển và do dân làm việc khác nhau nên
có nói khác nhau luôn ở trên thì rồi khẽ
khe nào kẹo ngồi trên máy bay có kiểu có
màn hình xem phim cái thử thử giờ thích
thoải mái tận hưởng con anh Vinh nhỉ lên
bìa các bạn sẽ nhận được cái gì Cái màn
hình thì bé tí rồi mờ thôi nhạt các thứ
thứ và đúng kiểu dân dân kiểu công nghệ
đánh giá thường mang thấy rất tệ ấy kiểu
như thế
Ừ thì tôi thấy à
Tôi không nói ai đúng hay sai ở đây của
phím mỗi người mỗi ngành rồi có thể là
còn liên quan đến việc là có bạn với
nhiều bạn bình luận là do là khi lên máy
bay đồ ăn bị thay đổi thời tiết thì nó
sẽ kiểu khác vị sau ở trên nhà đất ngập
trên mặt đất đấy
Ừ nhưng mà
ở mỗi góc nhìn nó lại khác nhau và nó
lại có thể con chiên hướng với các đối
tượng khác nhau bơ vân nữa Và thậm chí
là người xem cũng phải xem hoàn toàn
thân cả được xem cả ba được vì nó vẫn có
gì hay vẫn thêm được góc nhìn nên tôi
nghĩa về sau tôi làm vlog cơ hại là 2
hầm đấy blocker các thử thứ tôi nghĩ là
tôi vẫn sẽ không bị nhạt nhòa lắm không
phải là kiểu có rất nhiều người làm rồi
thì mình khung không nên làm mà mà là
kiểu mình Minh chỉ cần mình có một phong
cách khác mình không bị giống kiểu một
sau một cái gọi là sao chép ai đó quá
mình không có gì nổi bật thì đúng là
mình sẽ bị nhạt nhòa thôi còn một khi
mình cũng có cái điểm riêng của mình thì
Anh có bao nhiêu người đã từng làm rồi
thì mình cũng chặn không sao này
chứ ví dụ Giả sử Trong điểm mấy ông thấy
ngay chính cái kênh của tôi
dạy học đây này có rất nhiều rồi là
người đã dạy học rồi nhưng mà tôi dậy
tôi dậy tôi không bảo là kiểu các bạn
kiểu sẽ chỉ đi học của tôi chẳng đi học
của ai cả mà là có người cảm thấy phù
hợp thì có hoàn toàn có thể dùng kênh
của tôi là một cái tham khảo nữa để mà
thêm học cũng không cũng không đến nỗi
Tôi tập phải không ạ Được cái bình dân
tôi còn cảm thấy là tự nhiên các lãi
kiểu hôm trước tuần trước 800.000 lên
đến triệu hai thôi tôi phải làm gấp
ai giống như người này một người bảo là
120 120 củ alo E200 của vậy
E200 cụ Vì vậy một vé Ừ đúng rồi này
thấy hay bằng nhau bởi vì đều 5000 đô
đấy
sự kiện Hồ Chí Minh này thì tôi đang
chữa định là sẽ quay hò Cùng lắm mà nhờ
bên bên FPT shop quay thôi vì là tôi
cũng chạy show nhiều không tiện quay
đáng nhớ ở thế thứ hai là là tôi muốn
năm sau mấy là năm bắt đầu tôi bắt đầu
quay vì lót các thứ thứ Bởi vì tôi sẽ
mua iPhone thì nó sẽ quay công nhận vẫn
phải con nhận Tuy học Ghét hàng Apple
như quay bằng iPhone nó to hơn và tôi sẽ
mua thêm cả nghiệm bồ thì quay chống
rung cái thử nữa nữa cả cái á
Mày ghi âm thể ghi âm cho nó được đã
ừ ừ
Ừ anh em bình tĩnh Tôi không phản ánh ti
Apple thôi chả qua tôi get Apple nhưng
mà tôi vẫn là sơn công nghệ Nếu tôi
không thể phủ nhận được những ngày thứ
nó tốt và và cái thứ hai đó là
tôi Thực ra tôi thích nhiều hãng nữa
Huawei Google
Ừ vậy chiều cao thích mỗi hai hàng lấy
nữa thôi thì nhưng mà Google không bán
chính hãng tại Việt Nam còn Huawei thì ở
Huawei nó bị bóp và có vẻ vẫn chưa ổn
tại Việt Nam đang án đúng ở Việt Nam thì
mua iPhone vẫn được tài trợ từ a đến z
thêu kiểu lại hỏng hóc hay là điển hình
giống như điện thoại tôi giờ này bé Bây
giờ không có cái ốp đi mua ốp cho nó rất
là khó sẽ nặn thế này thì đúng là iPhone
thì nó đồ mọi thứ linh kiện đó nghe ngàn
thật đấy nên nên là tôi tôi nghĩa và
quan trọng và nó lại hệ điều hành khác
biệt tôi vẫn thích song song mình rằng
công nghệ mình vẫn thích kiểu song song
dùng dùng theo kiểu là 2 hệ điều hành
song song để một mình trải nghiệm nơi cả
hai chữ tô Tôi không phải là biến thành
một fan của Apple theo kiểu đổi hết sang
dùng hàng Apple không tẩy chay những cái
kiểu Android hay Windows không Tôi vẫn
thích dùng Ừ tôi vẫn thích dùng Android
nhưng tôi thích sự đan xen kết hợp nữa
Mỗi không có một thế mạnh này đúng như
bạn cái nói Thực ra về sau Thực ra tôi
lại lỡ mua con laptop mà nhẹ và gọn gần
đây rồi thế mà chả Tôi không có ý định
mua mắt đâu còn nếu mà nếu mà giả sử mà
ở cháu là không thiết về sau sẽ thế nào
nhưng đại khái thì về sau tôi sẽ điều
thêm con BC ở nhà để mà kiểu dạng như
muốn máy server thì thì chắc chắn là con
đây sẽ chạy linus chứ không phải chạy
Window bảo không thể chạy iOS
à Còn laptop nói cho laptop tôi mới mua
rồi nó ổn rồi đấy là tôi không có ý định
phải laptop
về sau cùng lắm là bưu một con chục con
mày tính cây cắm ở nhà thì chắc chắn nó
sẽ like rớt chứ không cũng không phải
mình cái hệ điều hành khác
cái nữa
những nhóm kiểu muốn chuẩn bị các thứ
muốn bảo vệ đâu hết rồi
ở chỗ uptool đấy à
11 tháng trước Đúng rồi thì mới kỷ niệm
1 năm thành lập chưa school mà cha ở sau
đó một thời gian thì mình dậy buổi đầu
tiên thử
em trả lời gì vậy à
Ý bạn hỏi gọi hỏi câu chuẩn đấy mấy ngày
hôm nay thật sự mình cũng không biết
mình đang livestream với mục đích gì Khi
mà mục đích chính là để mở chữabài các
bạn nhưng mà các bạn chẳng ngờ chữa gì
cả tôi lại mở cốt mà ông không lên xem
thì cậu chẳng hiểu được Nếu Quốc cái gì
tôi trước cả thì ra kia
tôi đang thấy đội mấy ông bình luận là
nhóm là cần chữa hai nhóm nào cần bảo vệ
thử thì thì con này bảo vệ đây
cái tài liệu cũ để ngồi làm tiếp thôi mà
người ông có thắc mắc gì cứ hỏi liên tục
vậy nha
năng thôi Nhưng mà ông bảo vệ thử buổi
trước để mua tính năng chưa Nếu mà chưa
Thì hôm nay để mô con còn rồi thì ông
ngồi làm thế là liệu được để nhường nhóm
Nam mà chưa bảo vệ thử cái tính năng đấy
anh đi phỏng vấn khoe làm solo hay vô
rách có đủ ấn tượng không thấy ông khoe
Thế cũng được nhưng mà đừng có nói là
kiểu
Em đừng có nói là cho giặc này em làm
với bạn khác cả bạn này bỏ bỏ bỏ em để
mà Thế em là một mình nữa người ta sẽ
cân nhắc lại với cái vụ làm cái nhóm của
ông đấy
cô được nhắc cái đấy nhé á
Ừ thì nó là cháu mình có hai cô trách
các thứ 22 đồ ăn thôi
em lấy cho để mua tính năng nhưng chưa
đủ à OK em Em muốn trình bày hôm nay từ
đầu đến cuối tính năng cũng được Nếu sử
hôm nay đầy đủ tính năng rồi thì muốn
bảo vệ thử nhưng mà chị tính năng chưa
có tài liệu cũng được
[âm nhạc]
đang có cái Tab ở đây là cho tim
community offline mình cũng tâm sự tí đó
à
Mỹ Tâm tự sự tí nữa là cầu ở ngay Chiều
nay vừa nãy mình vừa phải họp với bên
FPT shop để mà kiểu bàn về vụ offline ở
Hồ Chí Minh được ca là mình ở mọi người
dân công nghệ từng tổ chức sự kiện nhưng
mà vẫn còn mong do vẫn còn hiểu chứ
nghiệp thì cả chủ yếu là khả năng tự ứng
biến của mình nhưng mà Ông thấy là tôi
dạy học cũng thế nó có kỹ năng sư phạm
gì mấy cháu một kỹ năng sư phạm rồi Tôi
làm thế Mọi thứ theo cái Tâm cũng như
khả năng ứng biến món hơn thôi Hiểu chưa
lên một cái gì đó gọi là chuyên nghiệp
cả thế thế nên là hôm nay công nhận là
buổi học hơi toàn thật về việc người ta
hỏi phải câu kiểu về nội dung các thường
em chuẩn bị chưa Thì lúc mình chưa có gì
cả
nhưng mà
vì tính Tôi là một người cũng hơi
đa-zi-năng như thế sáng có thể học hỏi
thêm những cái này tôi ngồi là sang năm
thì thôi Con định là sẽ còn tổ chức thêm
Đà Nẵng hôm qua còn dự định còn thêm ở
Hải Phòng nữa chúc mừng các bạn Hải
Phòng có được ngắm lên vào mùa hè sang
năm bọn mình sẽ đi biển ờ và Hà Nội thì
chắc là nếu mà Hèn Hải Phòng sang năm
mình chắc là Hà Nội cho lại phải đúng
một năm nữa thì mới mới á
Ừ thế thì mới tổ chức nghĩa là
lấy bản đồ sinh nhật nhóm sau
này tôi vẫn khẳng định sẽ rất chuyên
nghiệp rồi làm việc ở bên FPT Họ yêu cầu
kể chuyên nghiệp Mọi thứ rất cao và đội
ngũ học cần sẽ là của bên họ để thành ra
là khung chương trình Em Mọi Thứ lên kế
hoạch xináp và đương nhiên miễn phí
nhưng miễn phí hết cái ông Nếu đi được
cứ đi
Ê bà quà sẽ rất nhiều
ừ ừ
có quá nhiều ấy một lần này ạ chắc chắn
ở riêng VOT lại có ba phần quà rồi
thêm cả
vì thế Thiên cả kiểu bên FPT và các file
vào sẽ còn kêu gọi thêm một vài nhà tài
trợ nữa đấy rồi không thiếu qua luôn
miễn phí không chưa qua xong rồi Được hỗ
trợ đưa đón các thứ thứ được antabax
được chưa chơi được giao lưu gặp gỡ họ
gặp gỡ băng quản trị không khẳng định
được là sẽ có những ai trong bản chị
nhưng chắc chắn sẽ có người da màu của
chị đây còn chờ đợi cái gì nữa à Đúng
rồi biết đâu Phát người yêu nữa chứ
em có bồ hết
sẽ là đang dự định sẽ là FPT ta Woa
trong Hồ Chí Minh không biết được nó là
cụ thể ở đâu cũng chưa chốt ngày tôi sẽ
báo lại ở trên ngòm như tim nhé người
tình của video sau
chưa Ừ tôi có đọc quay cả đấy tội định
dùng lúc đầu vì nó còn hỗ trợ còn liên
kết với cả thích shop nhưng nó toàn bộ
tài liệu đấy mới chỉ mức tương đối phải
bởi vì nó không tinh chỉnh được nhiều
cái tự ra tôi cảm thấy mai khi tao không
dùng bằng việc cho tôi dùng ở đấy có
những cái về sau tôi muốn tối ưu hơn ở
bên Altis sơ thì không làm được nên là
chắc là tôi dùng phần cái losless cao
đấy nó lá là nó chỉ Thằng thứ ba trung
gian để kết nối với những á nói hơn
trung gian để kết nối những thằng khác
ví dụ như là thằng nền tảng sơ khai thì
tôi khuyên là có khi ở ông dùng hẳn cả
cái nên đành shop khác còn xịn hơn bởi
vì nó còn à mình mình muốn tinh chỉnh
mình 4 kiểu cá nhân hóa Optimum setting
cho thử thì nó sẽ sẽ xịn hơn
ở
nơi nào chưa khí ông cốt ở chỉ sót một
cái trứng đồ chơi mà không cần tinh
Chỉnh gì đó thì ông thể dùng
phải trả lời cậu đấy nhà bỏ luôn Nó ra
vậy
Em hãy thế Tôi không biết phải game nữa
chịu
full stack không ạ tôi không Bạn nào
bình luận cái gì à Bạn nào nhắn tin hỏi
hỗ trợ gì tôi sẵn sàng trợ giúp thôi
nhay nhay nhay hiện tại luôn Bạn có một
bạn vừa mình nhắn cho tôi hỏi là thầy có
nhớ em không Em là sinh viên cũ ở hoài
Bây giờ mai em bảo vệ được hàng tốt
nghiệp bãi vừa nhắn tin luôn này thấy có
cái gì chia sẻ góp ý cho em được không
thì thì tôi hoàn toàn vẫn hỗ trợ tôi vẫn
nhớ bạn ấy thôi không đôi khi không hiểu
tên như tôi sẽ nhớ mặt và nhiều tính
cách và đôi khi giả sử kẻ không nhớ rõ
vẫn sẵn sàng giúp bạn đấy Nên là các bạn
cứ thoải mái không Tôi bảo tôi bảo chơi
trò cam kết bảo bảo hành trọn đời nhé
Đây là về sau không biết được rồi mày
cho lập gia đình có bị dính công việc
nhiều không tứ đại phái bây giờ cứ khi
nào rảnh cho vẫn sẽ hỗ trợ các bạn không
phải lo
vậy Anh không cần ở sâu cái gì đâu trừ
khi là ông có thể đẩy lên website rồi
còn không thì ông sẽ chỉ cần nói qua là
qua những cái vô rách đấy hở mô Chắc cái
bản chất ông làm những cái tính năng gì
nghiệp vụ là gì đấy Sau đó ông rút ra
được những cái gì thế thôi không Không
cần phải mùi nói không cần phải sau hết
ra đâu
thì có cách nào hợp lý không
à à
được không
về tội không biết luôn nghe nghe qua rồi
thì như hình như là
Ừ hình như là có đọc qua nhưng mà cũng
không
Ý anh hỏi rõ hơn em nhỉ
vì chính mình cũng chưa đồ dùng mấy thật
là đi làm các công ty như mình đã nói là
khi vào công ty mấy ông mấy anh ấy làm
sư out nó bảo tôi mới xin hết rồi Đây là
thành ra mình cũng chẳng được động vào
để mà tiếp xúc là mình không rành người
lắm
cái này nếu mà các bạn để ý kĩ thì à Thì
nó nó vừa là yêu vợ nhiều
ừ ừ
Ừ cái bản chất lỏng Facebook nó làm thế
nào để xác nhận được các bạn đang online
cái cái này nó liên quan đến cả không
xin và chặn cả đang hoạt động rất thứ
thử nhé anh online thì thì phẩm chất là
dùng Facebook nó sẽ Anh
Em có sẽ
khi mà trên máy các bạn nó sẽ liên tục
bắn cái gói tin lên hoặc là chiến thả nó
bắn gói tin về cho các bạn và các bạn
thông báo là nhận được ạ phản hồi lại
cho nó là nhận được
Ừ thì thì nó sẽ xác nhận là bạn nó ngon
và và xác nhận là bạn đã đọc tin nhắn
thì bây giờ bạn chỉ đơn giản và chặn
được cái việc xác nhận đấy Khi mà nó bắn
mà bạn thì bạn chặn không không gửi lại
cho nó cái gì cả thì nó sẽ nghĩ là bạn
đang họp lại thế thôi
và xin lắm thế mà chặn không cho nó biết
được và mình đã xem tin nhắn bằng cách à
em chặn những còi tim mình xác nhận là
mình vừa
anh không xác nhận là mình đã ngon này
và mình không xác nhận mình đã đọc cái
đấy do mà bạn có thể chơi cơ chế mèo nó
là bạn tắt sử mạng đi cho bạn mở tin
nhắn lên đọc vẫn được vì về các bạn thì
cái việc là tin nhắn gửi cho bạn
Nhóm ấy chỉ xác nhận là ừ máy bạn đã
nhận được tin nhắn chứ chưa xác nhận về
khoản là bạn đã đọc hay chưa
à Còn cái việc là khi mà xác nhận bạn đã
đọc hay chưa là bạn ấn vào thì nó xác
nhận không ạ nhưng mà bạn tắt sử mạng
rồi thì nó chưa Gửi chưa kịp gửi cái đấy
lên nữa là không ai biết được cả
đúng rồi thằng Facebook nó lại có rất
nhiều đi tổ yếu tố nhất là như bạn vừa
nói cũng đúng nó kiểu thằng Facebook ở
liên tục và liên tục truy quét liên tục
nếu mà các bạn Vào trang Facebook Xong
rồi ấn ấn F12 Mở tab lên request xr nó
sẽ đi người liên tục việc nên kiểm tra
thật con đã đang ngon liên tục nhá để mà
cái việc kiểm tra đã ngon nó con đó
Ừ cái việc kiểm tra là ngon đấy nó còn
liên quan đến việc là là nếu mà ông đang
ngon thì nó mới gửi thông báo mới trông
nên là cái tính năng chặn đã đang đang
hoạt động của thằng chị như tiên scuti
nó khiến cho mình phải tải lại trang
mình mới nhận được thông báo mới còn
không thì nó sẽ không tự động lấy thông
báo mới cho mình và vì mình đang ông
mình đã xác nhận là đã ngọt Mà này thứ
hai đó là nó sẽ lót liên tục tin nhắn
đến cả bài đăng với cái nó sẽ cuốn rất
là ram nó phải thì rất nhiều nó có đẩy
lên rất nhiều nó bị muốn làm thôi
à Còn YouTube thì YouTube Vì tôi chưa Để
nói Nhộn ngốn ram bao giờ nhưng mà ở
Ý tôi nói chung là bây giờ tôi dung Tôi
dùng bây giờ chắc chắn nó phải trên 16
hoặc 32 GB ra mình tôi không quan trọng
vấn đề làm nữa
hồi trước kia à xong không Tôi nhớ là
người trước và ạ khi mà chưa mò ra được
cái cái cái api để mà lấy được tin nhắn
theo mốc thời gian đấy
Ừ
rồi Sắp xếp theo mốc thời gian đấy thì
anh Tuấn với viết Hảo chơi cái trò là là
lấy tin nhắn đầu tiên thì nó sẽ cho trò
nó sẽ chơi trò là nhịn Tìm kiếm nhị phân
Anh hiểu để hay phết Nó kiểu nặng như
này
ở đây là 20 năm đi 25
à Không này kiểm tra xong 20 năm trước
đi không hẳn 20 năm nhưng mà đại khái
như thế sao rồi Kiểm tra là đây là
ngưỡng 10 năm đúng không
ở đầu tiên thì sẽ kiểm tra trước là tin
nhắn của bạn có nằm ở trong cái ngưỡng
từ 15 đến 20 năm hay không Nếu sử gặp có
thì tôi bắt đầu chia nhỏ tiếp thành 5
năm như thế này
ở đây nghĩa làm lên 15 năm nữa chứ tôi
kiểm tra tiết là có nằm trong 15 năm 20
năm hay không là xử thế đấy mà ngược lại
nhớ giờ xử ra
em kiểm tra trong 10 20 năm mà không có
thì bắt đầu ngồi kiểm tra trong
từ năm năm đến mười năm Đúng rồi Berry
shop Tìm kiếm nhị phân là virus gì đấy
sau đó đi tiếp thì ông cứ chưa nhỏ chưa
nhỏ ra thì thực á thì gọi năm đấy nhưng
mà người ta chưa nhỏ đến tầm 77 lần căng
thì vậy thì thì đã ra được cần nhiên là
một cái ngày gì đó khá chính xác rồi thì
lúc đấy
mặc nó lọc ra tin nhắn đầu tiên của ống
thôi Cái hôi đái ra chưa Bị mò được cái
api để sắp xếp tin nhắn nhưng thời gian
thì mình phải chơi cơ chế mà chỉ có có
apr là kiểu mình chuyển thời gian lên
cho nó thì nó trả về cho mình toàn bộ
tin nhắn trong ngày hôm đấy thôi nên
mình phải chưa Cái chọn này em gái mình
ở chơi lọc tài khoản thời gian như thế
để đoán xem và tin nhắn đầu tiên của bạn
là vào ngày hôm nào đấy chứ Facebook làm
gì còn lưu lại cụ thể là mình đã nhắn
tin cho bạn nào vào ngày hôm nào đâu
không Không đi được đâu lại nên là sẽ
cái cái cái cơ chế Xem nhà đầu tiên của
chư Tiên sẽ công ty ở làm theo cậu chỉ
như thế này Thế nên là các bạn thấy nó
ngồi loa loa loa loa để kiểu vào hình sẽ
nhận đầu tiên có bán loa tress dần đi
thì nó chơi cái chuyện anh nhé
Anh à hôm hôm qua tội không chết tôi mới
xem cái hay phết này cái này liên quan
đấy nữa
Em vừa kết hợp lệ quy nhưng và kết hợp
và phải dùng từ của nó ra hai a
Ừ cái này là
ngoài việc để quy rất là gì nó là kẻ có
thằng cho thằng cha là con đúng chị ạ và
thằng con này con thằn cháu rồi chắc cái
thứ n cấp nữa đúng hạn thì người ta gọi
đi Quy nghĩa là có rất có thể có rất
nhiều cấp có thể Cái này lương ăn menu
hoặc cái gì đó Tôi không biết nhưng cái
này nó con vật dụng rất hay Nó không chỉ
đơn giản có mỗi về cái quy đấy mà nó còn
chơi cho họ là đỡ nhớ vẫn bài toán về
việc có Thu Trang con
thế nhưng nó còn thêm cả vụ ở đây là tôi
cho mấy ông thấy cực liên quan đến
A
không ạ
Ừ cái có những cái hàm để dụ là gọi đến
Hàn này nó sẽ ra đến nó sẽ ra đến thằng
cao nhất cao nhất của cái cấp đấy cao
nhất của cái
trong này nó gọi là chui Tức là cái cây
mà nó rẽ cảo chiên nhánh chưa các ngành
nhánh cành là cái gì đó thì ah Shinzo
tất cả cái nó cái gốc cái gốc rễ có cái
cây đấy Cái
các tổ tiên mà ngon số điện thoại chi
cái khoảng hai ở dùng từ này huyết thống
rất hay nghĩa là lấy toàn bộ những cái
từ tổ tiên cho đến đấy thiểu cùng hết
hậu Nguyễn mình cùng anh ấy mình nó cứ
thế cả hai cái đấy Đúng đoạn tiếp theo
là chỉ lấy danh nghĩa thằng con này
những thằng con của những cái thằng nói
chung nhà Ví dụ mình đang ở mình đang ở
Càng đi cái sao mình lấy thằng con nó sẽ
những cái cái tán cây hay là cái lá gì
đó đấy
U60 lấy ra thằng lấy thằng cha của trực
tiếp của thằng này thôi không phải thằng
số tiên gì cả lại cũng được này đấy sao
còn xếp Linh là anh em anh em họ anh em
ruột này à chích lại ngay ruột chứ không
phải như mộng thì nó lấy kiểu cung cấp
cùng góc nhưng mà trong
ông cùng một cây này tại Khánh như thế
rất nhiều cái đặt tên hạnh rất hay à
ông Trung mà nó không biết được à bản
thân tôi thì tôi không biết áp dụng các
hệ thống trường hợp nào nhưng mà
Ừ cái này à cậu
Ừ cái này chắc ở hợp trong một mô hình
đa cấp của u xơ tự nhiên tự như đa cập
quá Cái này đúng cái này chứ phù hợp với
cả mô hình đã cắt gì đó Hoa hoặc Gà mô
hình liên quan đến việc là cái liên quan
đến việc là
làm cái sao cây gia phả rất là ổn bởi vì
cái này liên quan đến gọi đến đó
Ừ nó quay đi như thế nào á Quay đi là nó
sẽ là ở
đã có bản chất thằng leo nó quay qua đi
đã làm kiểu khi mà đa cấp như này nó nó
ừ nó thành hai câu hai câu truy vấn như
vậy
Thế mình không rõ nó làm nữa không biết
là thằng này có bắt chước kiểu đấy không
như nó sẽ ở We were in xong rồi nó sẽ
mát lại có thứ lăng nhăng quay in ID đấy
Mình không biết mình chưa cài thằng này
Chưa test được bạn thể về test Xem xem
Ví dụ ở xử với ông của tận 10 cấp ông
gọi đến tổ tiên của nó là Nhạn gọi thằng
dễ thì xem nó có thành 10 câu truy vấn
không Tôi nghĩ là không đâu làm thế chết
khi ngày nào hiện ở cậu chỉ cần thế 01
không nghĩ gì hết đã nhờ cái hài có thể
xuất ra chui lại là hai thì nó lít ra
các thứ thứ rất là ôn và thực sự là đấy
đôi khi ở mình mình phải tham khảo người
khác đúng không ạ để biết được à Buổi có
những người trên đời tư duy vãi thường
thì ngồi làm những cái đầu như thế này
này có thể chia ra khát Vàng Anh ấy các
thứ thứ nhánh này nó sẽ hiểu 1.1 1.1.2
có gì đó thì à
Ừ cái này đã Ví dụ nhé Không phải nó ra
thành số 123 thật đâu là nó bảo là có
thể thay đổi đường dẫn này các thứ để nó
sẽ hiểu dạng theo thành kiểu như này
Ừ cái này thậm chí nhưng mà ông thấy cái
này áp dụng cho chính cả mua mô hình
menu nhiều cấp được này không phải không
menu nhiều cấp có thể áp dụng được cái
này vậy nó sẽ lắc này là nó sẽ có cái
chéo là càng ổn không ạ này
Ừ cái này nó là để quy này Cái thấy cái
để quý ông nó xử lý phải toán đệ quy các
thứ từ xịn cho ông Phạm Chí cái này còn
làm cả mô hình nhà
đã hình được đấy
ở Texas công nhận đọc cái này thấy hay
phết
cho mấy ông này được mấy ông xem thông
Thảo tham khảo đây chúng ta phải sao
không áp dụng được đâu mà quan trọng là
mình thấy à Kiểu như ta nghĩ nghĩ bài
toán thường người đang nghĩ giải pháp
làm như thế nào và ra làm cái bắt vịt
kiểu như này làm như thế nào các bạn thể
tham khảo học hỏi tôi còn đang nghĩ là
tôi sẽ làm vì sao tôi sẽ có thể làm một
hai cái bát ít nào giao cũng được
anh cũng cũng cũng gọi là tôi bắt đầu có
ý tưởng để mà ngồi làm những cái Bắc
khít riêng nhưng mình rồi đâu có đang
làm riêng trên công ty mà ạ
thế nào
Ừ
cái ở để lưu toàn bộ ảnh TM thì sau tao
đang dần những trang của tôi như lâu lắm
không động là mua cái gì để lưu danh
sách các bạn nữ mà các bạn đấy không ạ
à Không để chế độ công khai hay gì đó để
tiện theo dõi tôi lưu lại để lấy sau
biết đâu Bạn ấy mở chế độ theo dõi thì
tôi ấn theo dõi
anh cũng chẳng có gì đâu nhưng nói chung
là đại khá gái xinh của tôi mà à
Nếu không cần trợ sẻ cái ông kia vừa bảo
là để mua các thứ ở đâu ấy nhỉ
bằng cách selling được ạ Cũng được mà
giống kiểu ở nó vẫn kiểu đã ăn tiền theo
kiểu dạng là chia chia các trường thứ
cấp các thứ mà đúng
ông sinh quan trọng mình lên mã hóa Ừ ừ
cái gì
class 2 phương trình ở tôi
à Tôi đang hiểu Cái ý của bạn thì nó là
là dùng khách hàng đọc được chốt à hay
là mà phải mã hóa nhỉ Hay là
Ừ nếu mà ra Suite thì thử tạ không cũng
đúng à mã hóa nhưng mà tới chị vẫn giải
mã ra được đâu
ở Châu Á à
ở đài squish à
Ừ nó gọi là ốc
cái gì đó đúng nôi bạn kìa không nhớ
chính xác từ đấy à
mã hóa lại cái Hà mình sao cho kiểu khó
đọc thôi nhớ vẫn đôi khi mà có mấy kiểu
ngay thì đôi khi họ vẫn dịch ra được à
em hết tiếp theo là
con để mà các bạn gửi chuột cốt cho bên
khác để nhưng mà
Anh không muốn bán hoàn toàn không muốn
cho nó kiểu ăn cắp ý tưởng nó cứ thứ gì
thì nhiều bên lại có nhiều cách khác
nhau
Ê bà đô thị vẫn có thể vẫn có thể hiểu
xuống kia vẫn thể dịch ngược có được
anh nói chung nào về vấn đề về Lysine
hijacker thương thứ nó vẫn nghe ngạo mạn
đúng không
còn như bạn muốn hỏi kỹ hơn ví dụ về với
ai Đi lại không muốn cho khách hàng thể
dịch ngược được cái đi học cả khó khó
tìm ID Các bạn thấy chính những cái
thằng thực tế những cái thằng lớn này
này ví dụ Các bạn đang để ý kỹ ngay trên
này đi đường rất dài như là để vừa để
tránh bị trùng lặp cũng khó người nào có
thể mới mò được ID của cái thằng khác để
mà ngồi xem được tài liệu của họ có vân
cũng như là nhưng mà có một vài đi cũng
để dễ nhớ người dùng thì nó chỉ con số
như cái thằng Facebook ở được
bảo mật từ đây một cách tương đối thôi
không có một cái gì thực sự là nó cái
bài toán để cho mình chắc chắn để bảo
mật cả kể cả mã hóa luôn nó đặc biệt nó
vẫn quan trọng vẫn là bài toán con người
vì nhiều hack Âu là nó không chơi trò là
nó khách vào phần mềm đâu Nó toàn khách
con người thôi
ừ ừ
Ok chào em Em muốn đi mua đúng không Dạ
vâng ạ Ok
em em thử để mua xem em này mu nốt phân
công giảng dạy và điểm danh cho giáo
viên tin học chia sẻ màn hình Ok em chia
sẻ đi
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
kết quả sau đó á sau cho tôi chỉ dậy lại
dậy lại
từ cái bớt đã dậy thôi Anh nhìn thấy
chưa Ok Rồi
phần Không giảng dạy à
anh em làm đơn giản thì em chỉ phân cực
làm trong khung cảnh lại chứ là một giáo
viên chỉ dạy cho một lamu là một lớp ạ
thì mình sẽ có chọn quá thì chọn quá thì
sẽ như lấy ra những chuyên ngành cục quá
đấy
xe lu mà khi chọn lại phân công giảng
dạy thì những cái giáo viên nào biết thì
vẫn ngồi thì mình mình định đi đấy em em
vừa thấy chính cái Em vừa làm nó hơi bị
mất công một tí ở bây giờ sử có rất
nhiều giáo viên đúng không em còn nói
lại trang làm cho kiểu mình lại phải
chọn lại cái phần phân công từ đầu đúng
không Bởi vì bây giờ em có rất nhiều lớp
mà đúng không em có rất nhiều lớp thì ở
các lớp đấy cũng sẽ học tất cả những cái
môn Nếu mua chung một khóa tất cả lớp
học môn như nhau rồi được chứ Thì cái
này một là em làm tự đọc được thì tốt
hay hay là kiểu phải làm sao cho mà khi
mà chọn chọn là tay đấy anh anh hình anh
từng chia sẻ ở em em vẫn đang mở YouTube
nghỉ Dạ vâng ạ Anh hiểu anh từng chia sẻ
các bạn đấy thì khi mà làm phân công thì
ở mình có thể mát lại vả lại cũng được
nhưng mà tại lại ở một cái mức tương đối
thôi chứ đừng lót hẳn lại như thế thì
người dùng bia lạ anh vỡ mồm
[âm nhạc]
à à
nằm ở đây đây
đây anh thử cho em xem thử cái công của
anh nha
anh
king kong anh cũng chọn khó ấy cũng chọn
ngành này chọn giáo viên này chọn môn
này muốn nói chọn tất cả các lớp học môn
này luôn như này hay ở chọn cụ thể
thương lượng những cái lớp mà học môn
này anh khóa này anh hơi ít hỡi Cái chọn
thử
đây có thể chọn nhiều môn cùng nốt luôn
và chọn tất cả các lỡ cùng một lúc luôn
được như thế này hoặc đây như là luôn
đúng không Và khi mà chọn xong giả sử
khi chọn xong cập nhật này thì em sẽ
thấy đó à sẽ hiểu không phải chọn lại
cái đó ngày nữa vì vừa có bản thì khi mà
mình lên một cái nhanh
lên một cái nhanh thì ạ Cái khóa và cái
chương trình đào tạo này
mình vẫn phải cố điên nốt tất cả kiểu
khóa mới và đúng không đến là mình phân
công chỉ liên quan để khóa mới thôi nên
là mình vẫn sẽ chọn lại khóa cũ để vẫn
chọn về chương trình đấy cũng lắm mà
mình sẽ đổi giáo viên thôi Bây giờ mình
sẽ đổ Nhớ lại hồi đấy anh chưa làm vụ
đổi đổi giáo viên nhảy sang giáo viên
tiếp theo nên anh mới kiểu phải phải yêu
cầu chọn lại Giáo viên thì nó mới hiển
thị lại cái này nhé em Em Minh dung được
cái kiểu nào cho hình lại cho như thế
lại mất công anh có
5 lớp mới thôi để đã thấy hơi khó chịu
một tí thôi đúng không ạ
hát hiển thị sao chạy tốt trên Firefox
bởi vì trên trên máy trình duyệt ở trên
các máy ở trường của tôi không hiểu sao
Chrome phiên bản cũ rồi phải với dùng
Window đi đâu gì
không không hỗ trợ của ông Khi mà mới
nhất nhưng thấy ra là kiểu phần mềm tôi
bị lỗi nỗi nhiều Cám đôi khi ở một lỗi
chỉ diễn ra lỗi cái xe Lead 2 này hình à
dùng trên fifo thôi Chứ mày Ông thấy tôi
dùng trên chrome ở trên chính máy tôi
đang dùng để lại rất bình thường nhưng
trên máy các cô cũng không hiểu sao lỗi
tùm lum lên nguồn lỗi là nói nó diện đấy
đấy bởi vì Và đôi khi có lỗi về giá
Speed thật của vì is phiên bản cũ ấy à s
mấy cái thời nên là thôi bảo là dùng
xăng pha à à
Ừ Ok nghỉ của em có mỗi phần thân công
còn gì nữa
còn đăng ta
đến anh cho giáo viên tiếng Anh là viên
thì hôm trước mua điểm đáng rồi nhỉ thấy
có nhiều không Em mới đề mua điểm danh
cho ráo vụ ạ Ông không giáo viên bây giờ
vụ thì nó vẫn ta điểm ngay đâu mà còn
còn gì nữa
á nhon
thì người ta mới dừng lại ở đây đúng
không phân công này xong thì giáo viên
vào sẽ hiển thị ra giao diện như nào gửi
cho anh xem à
tạo tài khoản cho giáo viên cho tao
anh đã chút
Ừ ok
à à
công
[âm nhạc]
nghệ mạng làm chi đã được phân công cho
lớp ngại nước này và mua này thì vào sẽ
hiển thị ra luôn ạ Đã có chọn mà một
giáo viên dạy nhiều lớp nhiều môn mà em
làm đơn giản thì chỉ một giáo viên lại
cho một đêm là một lớp
Ừ thế thì không phải phù hợp với trường
đại học rồi
Ừ nó kiểu dạng như là một cái trường
kiểu trường hợp lớp bổ túc trường nghề
hơn
Anh ở trường đại học tại chất Thành Nam
một giáo viên dạy nhiều lớp nhiều môn
nhưng đúng không Vâng ạ
xe hoa cùng lắm là trường em à phù hợp
đái giống kiểu trường nghề rồi tuyển
giáo viên parttime kiểu dạng là khi mà
có một cái lượng sinh viên nhất định rồi
thì mở lớp xong rồi thuê một giáo viên
nào đó với dạy các lớp vậy thôi thì nó
mới làm theo mô hình được
làm thế thôi thì em phải à Ừ chắc ai em
inbox là anh Dương thì sẽ anh xem lại
latop Asus em tao bye em thiết kế theo
cả phù hợp với với độ như nào nữa kem
sau xong rồi anh sẽ góp ý thêm nhóm em
phù hợp theo kẹo mô hình nha Ok em
nghĩ chắc là hết rồi ạ Ok cảm ơn em đã
Vâng em chào anh ạ chứ
39 được rồi tội xin phép bây giờ
nếu mà các bạn không hỏi lên thì ra tôi
cũng phải nghỉ sớm thôi à ngủ Hôm nay cả
may bị đến like xì hơi hơi gặp lại cái
vụ đáy tôi bảo lấy lại khung chương
trình cho yêu cũng như à Mấy hôm nay ở
ngồi cốt để trên công ty không có mấy cứ
chạy show liên tục hôm qua còn vừa đi xe
mà bên là đấy in inox chuột chất lượng
như nào rồi đấy gọi như là thương lượng
giá với họ các thứ thứ
kêu gọi tài trợ nữa Ừ mấy hôm nay nói
chung là tháng 2 ở tôi bảo một tháng sau
nó bận rộn người tôi nhưng tôi muốn là
kẻo mình bảo vệ mình bảo vệ gọi là ồn
hỏa và nói chung là cũng sớm xong sớm
chứ càng về cuối tháng sẽ càng bận thì
khó vậy thôi Định trong tuần này nhưng
mà các bạn thế này thì chắc là phải nuôi
lại sau tuần sau
anh nói chùa cố cũng bảo vệ sớm hơn
không nhỉ tội không có thời gian được
bảo vệ các bạn không ít sang tháng mà
mệt hơn nữa đấy
diện đi
thứ bảy tuần này mà
anh không nhỉ Chả thứ bảy tuần sau đi
tạm Mình chốt thì bây giờ sau nhé
đa số các bạn ạ
anh nói cho cũng phải ổn thì mới bảo vệ
Chắc chắn rồi nhưng mà cũng không cần
phải kiểu quá hoàn hảo đâu
Ê bà đặc biệt là tôi phải kiểm tra Tôi
nắm bắt được kiểm soát được cả các bạn
đang như nào các bạn có gì không một
mình thôi chị luôn Tôi không biết được
các bạn là như nào thì một cái trình cả
chỉ hơn mình
hôm nay tạm kết thúc rồi nha Ừ nhưng mà
nói chung hợp các bạn có thắc mắc gì thì
vẫn đi Bóp của mình để mình hỗ trợ luôn
nhá thì thôi luôn nắm rõ tình hình chứ
không
Ừ Ok chào các bạn nhé